beyoncé and jay-z's nannies get paid how
much kendall jenner puts it all out
there about her sexuality and Blake
Griffin Plus why Selena Gomez and Justin
Bieber maybe spending some time apart
while Gwen Stefani and Blake Shelton are
still going strong hello everyone
if you watch the daily denne then you
are well aware that jay-z and Beyonce
are headed back on tour this summer for
their on the run to shows you all get
your presale tickets because I did not
well as I hunkered down for the general
sale on Friday how are the parents of
three preparing for life on the road
well Blue Ivy and twins certain roomie
are expected to be along for the ride
and et has learned that means the
Carters will have a team of helpers who
are already in place for the superstar
brood no surprise here but a source
tells et Beyonce and jay-z splurged on
around-the-clock care for their kids and
have a team of nannies working for them
mister mrs. Carter reportedly hired six
nannies with each getting paid 100 grand
a year and I'm like can I get that
babysitting gig and listen if you think
it's just the nannies who are living
large guess again because it is also
good to be Blue Ivy our sources say the
big sister is a little fashionista one
of Blue Ivy's favorite things to do
aside from her she and her parents at
award shows is shopping favorites
include this eight hundred and sixty
dollar Gucci denim jacket and this six
hundred and fifty dollar dress
both to match her mama's I mean if I
can't be Beyonce and Jay Z's Manny can
y'all adopt me of course the only celeb
kid that might come close to outdoing
Blue Ivy is North West and Nori's aunt
Kendall Jenner's get all kinds of candid
in the new interview with vogue the 22
year old covers the magazine's April
issue and the girl looks good inside the
mag Kendall addressed those rumors
regarding her sexuality remember when
the internet speculated she was gay well
she does an explained quote I think it's
because I'm not like all my other
sisters who are like here's me and my
boyfriend I would always go that extra
mile to be low-key with guys
get around all the time well Kendall
sets the record straight though she says
she would never hide something like that
but she's not gay what she didn't
confess though was whether or not she's
dating Detroit Pistons player Blake
Griffin but Kendall did admit there's a
special guy in her life quote I'm happy
he's very nice adding I have someone
being very nice to me okay we haven't
done this in a minute but I think it's
time to bust up the John Legend and
Chrissy Teigen relationship goal scale
Kendall and Blake we hardly know ya and
he's nice isn't enough for me so we're
giving you a 2 on the John and Chrissy
scale that being said Kendall is happy
but she's not quite ready to settle down
and start a family she says she wants
kids at like 28 or 29 but she does add
she loves watching her 20 year old
sister Kylie take on motherhood and adds
it's already made them closer
alright meanwhile Justin Bieber and
Selena Gomez rekindled their
relationship last year but we've since
learned that they'll be spending some
time apart
but don't worry jelena fans the two are
still together according to our source
but she is taking a step back to repair
her relationship with her mother
adding that's a priority for her
Selena's been overwhelmed by the media
attention surrounding her family's
contentious relationship with Justin
we're told she's very delicate and her
comeback to the spotlight has been tough
she hasn't had her mother to lean on
this time and that's been difficult for
her ét previously reported Selena's
friends and family particularly her
mother Mandy were struggling with the
couple's reunion back in January which
in turn put a strain on their
mother-daughter relationship while
Selena's apparently taking time to be
with her family outside of LA and needs
to figure out how to live the life she
wants in the spotlight tonight I say
take care of you some leaves Biebs ain't
going nowhere and the same can be said
for Gwen and Blake who are still going
strong folks in fact a source close to
the couple tells ET they are on cloud 9
for each other quote they know they have
found their true soulmate
and despite reports at the pop star the
country crooner are heading down the
aisle soon our source says they see no
reason to rush into marriage quote both
of them are happy and content with where
their relationship
is right now also content gwen's three
boys who enjoy spending quality time
with blake and see him as a father
figure as for Gwen's relationship with
ex Gavin Rossdale
our source says they are very cordial
and make co-parenting work and that's
how you act like grown-ups Gwen and
Blake seemed like an odd pair at first
but they are in it and given John and
Chrissy a run for their money which is
why we're gonna give them an 8 on the
scale yeah if you give this video a 10
once you give us a thumbs-up and of
course comment and share we'll be back
tomorrow with another daily Denny so
make sure you guys are subscribed to our
YouTube channel gotta figure out how I'm
gonna get those Beyonce tickets
[Music]